(applaudissements)
- Il y avait de l'amour dans
l'air lors du spectacle des
finissants de l'École national
de l'humour.
- Je pense que j'ai
le VIH... eille... c'est
un show d'humour, ostie!
- C'est l'fun, on s'en va vers
quelque chose de positif, les
salles réouvrent.
- Moi, je pourrais battre
n'importe quel gars avec
la corne que j'ai sous le pied.
- Ces comiques ont étudié l'art
de la blague pendant deux ans
et pandémie oblige,
ça s'est passé.en bonne
partie par Internet.
- Mi-homme, mi-perchaude,
un mythique surf and turf!
Avec mon TDHA c'est pas
la chose la plus facile
de me concentrer sur Zoom.
Tu t'appelles Tommy, tu dis si
j'aurais
- La compétition sera forte
pour ces finissants, car après
le confinement, ça se bouscule
aux portes pur monter du scène.
Avec leur diplôme en poche,
la relève devra se tailler
une place dans les bars
et sur le web.
- On part des projets, puis
on est par nous-même. C'est pas
un taux de placement.
Il faut continuer de s'amuser.
Il y a une vague qui m'a frappé,
j'étais nu boule,j'ai vécu
la première vague METOO
- Dans cette cohorte
de la pandémie, il n'y a
visiblement pas de membres
de communautés culturelles
et parmi les 14 finissants
il y a seulement deux femmes.
- C'est tellement bizarre d'être
deux filles. C'est moi c'est
moins que le minimum. Une fille
c'est trop bizarre..deux filles,
je ne sais pas ça tellement été
bizarre.
LOUISE RICHER, directrice
générale fondatrice ENH
- Ça me dit que c'est pas
beaucoup, mais je vais rétorquer
en vous disant que la nouvelle
cohorte qui vient d'entrer
d'humoristes de première année,
il y a sept filles et six gars.
- Elle n'en explique des
affaires ma blonde et elle
m'explique que moi j'écoute.
C'est important d'écouter.
- Les nouveaux finissants de
l'École nationale de l'humour
ont soif de monter sur scène et
il peuvent compter sur l'appui
de Katherine Levac qui assistait
à leur spectacle.
Katherine Levac, Humoriste
- Il y a énormément de talents
je les suit depuis le début.
C'est une gang de j'aime
beaucoup, j'ai beaucoup d'amis
dans le groupe. Je les vends ce
soir, c'est touchant. C'est un
show qui est touchant le show
des finissants.
- Il avait un beau linge
à vaisselle sur l'épaule, je te
jure, ça n'avait jamais vu de
vaisselle ce linge-là.
- En ces temps incertains,
l'humour est un des remèdes
à la grisaille. Parfois, il vaut
mieux en rire que d'en pleurer.
- Essaie de mieux manger,
je mange très bien. Je sais la
nourriture varie, je ne fais pas
de miettes, ma technique est
excellente.
Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada, M